What if your biggest insecurity,
>> what are these for?
>> Oh, that's a to sit on.
>> became the thing.
>> You really got to hand it to Kevin Hart
cuz he can't reach.
>> People always make fun of you for
>> I wish I was this tall, but I'll never
get this tall.
>> What makes him not your type?
>> Probably the height. It's the height.
>> It's solely just height for me. It's cuz
you're short.
>> These days, everyone seems obsessed with
improving their appearance. Some want to
be thinner,
others want to be stronger,
and some guys just want hair.
>> I'm going bald.
>> The truth is that insecurities are
normal. What's changed is how far some
people are willing to go to fix them.
>> Looks maxing.
>> The trend can range from superficial
practices like hairstyle and skin health
to serious measures like breaking bones
in your face. We live in a deeply
imageconscious [music] society with
enormous pressure from dating apps and
online influencers to look a certain
way. Online personalities like
clavvicular have built massive
followings on the idea that confidence,
status, and success purely comes down to
how you look. I am getting a double jaw
surgery. Why are you spending $100,000
on surgery to go from 6'2 to 6'6? That
is more about presence.
>> Now, I don't mean this as an insult, but
it is worth noting. Pavvicular is
already a foot taller than Kevin Hart.
And yet Kevin has more [music] presence
and charisma in just about every room
that he walks into.
>> Dwayne, you also just recently bought
your mom a house.
>> I think the whole room right now is
thinking the same thing. It's about
[laughter]
>> So what's his secret? Well, I think it's
that Kevin fully owns who he is without
shame. Or as one of my favorite
characters of all time says,
>> "Never forget what you are. The rest of
the world will not.
Wear it like armor.
and it can never be used to hurt you.
>> We all have something we're
self-conscious about. For Kevin, it just
so happened to be the first thing people
noticed about him.
>> Are you
5'2?
>> Absolutely not. 5'4.
>> GQ said you're 5'5. The LA Times says
you're 5'4. [music] And some other place
said you were 5'2.
>> 5' five? Like with a shoe on,
>> Kevin?
>> 5 foot two and a half.
I'm 5 foot two. 5 foot two. Let's try to
tell the truth.
>> Yeah, 5'2, too.
>> Are you self-conscious about your
height?
>> Yes.
>> You think you have a complex about it?
>> I can't I can't even say thank. I can't
be dishonest. I know I do.
>> We were at a restaurant one time, right?
And I snapped on her. We were at the
table. We're ordering food and uh the
waiter leaves. A man waiter came back. I
was talking to her. She like followed
him and he was tall and I I snapped. I
was like, "Is that what you want?" You
see, when you're insecure about
something, it consumes way more of your
time than you probably realize. It's the
30 minutes that you spend looking into
the mirror before a date. Or it's the
photo that you have to retake [music]
six times to get it perfect. The 5
minutes that you spend looking for that
hat that you can't leave the house
without. Most of the time, no one else
is even thinking about these things, but
you are. And for Kevin, that thing was
impossible to hide. And his first
instinct, like many of ours, wasn't to
own it with pride. It was to build a
persona that masked it. I seen a guy
named Kevin Hart, but he called himself
that at that time.
>> Lil Cab the Bastard. [music]
>> Lil Cab the Bastard
>> was my first stage name. My early days
of comedy, it wasn't fueled and filled
with a lot of confidence. [music] One of
my friends gave me a stage name. He was
like, "Yo, you got to go by the bastard.
Little Kev the Bastard. That's what your
name should be." When the host said,
"Little Kev the Bastard," I felt like I
was someone else and I could be someone
else on stage. and would say, "Give it
up for little Kevin the Bastard and I
would just run through the doors and I
would grab the store and I Yeah, man.
Was it?" I was talking a mile a minute.
But at the time, I wasn't Kevin Hart.
[music] I wasn't being myself. I was
being a version of what I thought I
should be to get laughs.
>> What strikes me is that this persona,
this character functions like a shield.
If a joke bombed, it wasn't really Kevin
that was bombing. It was Lil Kev the
Bastard. And that level of protection
gave him the courage to go on stage and
risk humiliation. Now, I felt a similar
impulse when I started Charisma [music]
on Command. I actually debated using a
moniker instead of my real name, so if
people judged me, Charlie wasn't the one
that they'd be judging. Maybe you felt
this way, too. Maybe you've become the
funny one because making people laugh
[music] feels safer than letting them
see that you're nervous. Maybe you've
become the person who doesn't need
anybody because rejection hurts less
when you never put yourself out there.
Different masks, same purpose. The
problem is that the character doesn't
always work. I tried to tell some jokes,
man, they weren't having it. That's
that's when I got hit with a buffalo
wing. Some of the saws went in my eye. I
remember telling this joke and a phone
book comes flying on the stage. All you
heard was and [music] you sit back. The
joke doesn't work. And I remember this
lady just going, "Oh no." Sometimes
Kevin could get laughs, but even then
nobody knew who he actually was. And it
wasn't just the audiences. One of the
biggest comedy bookers in New York named
Lucian Hold had some discouraging words
for Kevin as well.
>> There's a part in the book where you
talk about being told no a lot.
>> Lucian was a guy who ran a comic strip
comedy club in New York. The eyes that
Lucian had for comedy were supposed to
be the ultimate eyes for [music] talent.
I'm in New York. I'm trying to get into
these comedy clubs. I land an audition.
They set up a time for Lucian to go and
see me. I kill. Lucian calls me off the
stage, calls me to come in his office
without [music] any pause, hesitation.
He goes, "I don't think comedy is for
you. I think that you should find
something else."
Had to get up, go out his office. Keith
Robinson, who was a mentor, I go out
there, he's like, "What'd he say?" And I
was like, "He told me that I shouldn't
be doing comedy. That basically I'm not
funny. This isn't for me. I need to find
something else." My boy Keith was like,
"Fuck lotion." But Keith wasn't done.
>> Get rid of Little Cam the Bastard.
I don't want that. What's your full
name?
>> And even Chris Rock gave the same
advice.
>> Your problem is you're competing with
these other comedians. They are not your
peers. You're better than all of them.
But you need to get out of their circle
and develop your own voice. So, two
people who had gone through it
themselves told Kevin that the character
was the problem, not the solution. And
because Kevin knew that advice was
coming from a place of love, he
listened. So, it wasn't until I started
to figure out that I didn't have to be a
character that I got really funny.
Whether we are aware of it or not, we
all have characters that we play in
different social settings. The quiet
one, the funny one, the one who has it
together. Now, most of these characters
exist for just one reason, and that's to
manage how other people see us. Deep
down, a lot of us are terrified of what
will happen if we aren't liked. Kevin
finally stopped playing that game. And
it wasn't because he stopped caring, but
because he [music] decided that whatever
happened, he would be okay. And when
nothing terrible is at stake, you can
just stop managing other people. You
show up, you can afford to be honest and
name the vulnerable thing first before
anyone else can use it to insult you.
For example, say you're on a first date
and you're feeling nervous. Now, you
could spend the whole dinner performing,
or you could just start it off by
saying, "You know, I'll be honest. I
always find the first few minutes of
these incredibly awkward." She'll
probably laugh because she was feeling
the same thing, and you are the one that
was brave enough to say it. [music] The
whole dinner can change from that point
onward. Or say you're in a meeting,
somebody asks you about something that
you're not sure about. You could bluff
your way through and just hope that
nobody notices. Or you could say, "I
actually haven't done this before. Could
somebody walk me through?" Say somebody
does. You learn how to do it properly
and you do it well. Six months later,
you're going to be the one that is
actually being asked [music] to help
others. That is charismatic mindset
number six. I go first. And it makes you
a natural leader. But there is a catch,
and that's that people can tell the
difference between someone who names the
thing first because they've made peace
with it and someone who's just trying to
beat everyone else to the punch. The
first one disarms the room, and the
other just signals that there's
something to protect. Kevin truly owned
his insecurity, and that gave him the
confidence to start leading with it and
having fun with it. She's like, "All
right, well, get out. Come talk to me."
Now, I can't get out my truck. You know,
I got to jump out, right?
I'm small. I get scared fast. My food
comes out. He says, "Enjoy your meal." I
said, "Thank you, sir." I take my
napkin. Put it on my lap. Reason why I
go f this big to me cuz I'm small. Takes
up a lot of space.
>> By putting that insecurity front and
center in his comedy, he made it
impossible for anyone else to undermine
him because he'd already said the
uncomfortable thing. There was nothing
left to reveal, nothing to protect, and
nothing that anyone could take from him.
When someone has something to defend,
other people can feel it, and the world
starts to notice that thing.
>> You sold out Madison Square Garden,
which is something that very few comics
have ever done. Is that when you knew
you'd made it?
>> It was around this time that a Kevin
Hart show became a must-see event. And
without that weight, Kevin becomes one
of the most magnetic personalities
alive. He's not afraid to interrupt
interviews or to take over a Leno couch
to roast Shaq.
>> Remember when you had your jam toe that
time?
>> You remember, right?
>> Remember and you [laughter] was like,
you were fine. Someone was like, "Shack,
you jammed your toe." You like
>> And that thing that he used to brace
for, he's now genuinely able to laugh at
it even when other people poke fun.
>> Well, what happens if you're 3'2? Like
how does that
>> how do you how do you
>> talking about
>> tall people are stupid. [laughter]
It's we rock. Little guys, little women
rock. We rock.
>> Oprah noticed it, too.
>> How did you get so comfortable with your
height? Generally, you know, people who
are not 6 feet tall have a complex about
it.
>> I'm beyond confident. I'm not cocky. I'm
so confident. That's not someone
managing in insecurity. That is someone
who has genuinely made peace with
themselves. And when you're that
comfortable with yourself, the people
around you will naturally feel a sense
of relaxation in your presence.
>> I don't believe in [music] in doing
things to manufacture my body to appeal
to what I think people might like.
>> Put that together and it's the whole
game. That's you unlocking the version
of yourself that actually shows up
around your close friends when you're
relaxed and present and not worried
about being judged. Then you learn how
to bring that person into every room,
even when you don't know people. But not
everyone responds to insecurity in that
healthy way. There's a new generation
that is led by influencers like Braden
Peters, and they're making the opposite
choice. And I think this is where Braden
deserves compassion because he is still
operating inside the mindset of those
early shamefilled years. On the face of
it, looks maxing is just that,
maximizing appearance. A kind of
self-improvement that makes them
irresistible to others.
>> The trend can range from superficial
practices like hairstyle and skin
health,
>> drugs, surgery, and even self harm,
using a hammer to smash their faces to
try to realign bone structures. Braden
looked at his problem and solved it the
way that an engineer would. He
identified what he believed to be his
flaws and then set about fixing them.
While doing so, he took on the name
clavvicular.
>> Were you a loader growing up?
>> Yeah.
>> You were online a lot during lockdown.
>> I was definitely uh on the internet
probably 14 hours a day. I would have
been 13. I was in 8th grade. And March
of of 2020 is when they sent us all home
virtually. And that was the last time I
interacted with people normally for
another 2 or 3 years. Now, most of us
figure out some part of who we are
through relationships with other people,
our friends, our classmates, all sorts
of social interactions. Now, Braden did
that almost entirely online. And what he
found in those online forums would end
up defining how he saw himself.
>> I was extremely subhuman. I would say
that those were my worst two years
look-wise. Then I realized, you know, my
looks percentile was and that it really
wasn't even worth an effort. What does
subhuman mean?
>> It's just a term that we use. It was
just part of the rating scale that's
just calling them ugly.
>> Kevin had a Keith Robinson at his
mentor. Braden had the internet, a place
that told him that if you become
attractive enough, all your problems
will be solved.
>> Nobody's [music] born with shame. The
Chuck can believe there's something
wrong with me. And maybe if I can work
hard enough,
we'll look good enough.
I can fix it.
>> I knew I would ascend eventually.
>> And here's the thing. Once you really
believe this type of self-improvement is
necessary, every experience becomes
proof. Back when I was working as a
server, I knew that if I was better
looking, that that would pay itself off
because I knew that, you know, your
looks play into a role of are you going
to get hired, right? How people treat
you just in terms of how I was getting
tipped. Like Kevin Hart, Braden built a
persona to defend his insecurity. But
Kevin had people that told him that the
character wasn't the right choice
forever. Braden had the internet, and
the internet doesn't just tolerate
personas. It's built on them. Usernames,
handles, avatars. Most people are
already wearing a mask. And the internet
doesn't usually reward the version of
you that's thoughtful or honest or
working through something in real time.
It rewards the version that is extreme,
that's controversial, and often times
superficial. So the question that people
are asking themselves isn't, is this
persona helping me reveal more of
myself? The question becomes, how do I
make this character more noticeable? So,
you fix your jaw angle, fix your frame,
fix your height to shoulder width ratio,
and it takes that feeling that is deep
inside of I'm not enough, and it turns
it into a to-do list. So, you fix this,
then this, then this, and eventually you
will ascend. Most people don't take it
as far as Braden, but the pattern is
familiar. We have this belief that once
I get promoted or once I lose 20 lbs or
once I feel confident, then I will
finally be okay. But the problem is that
that checklist never ends. [music]
Because the shame that you're feeling
isn't actually about your jaw angle.
Every to-do list item quiets that
feeling for a moment, but then it comes
back in the form of another thing that
you have to get right or change.
>> When did you start taking testosterone?
>> When I was 14 years old.
>> What about bone smashing?
>> It's where you induce um micro
fractures. And this principle follows
Wolf's law that a bone is going to grow
back stronger. You know, after you
induce these localized micro traumas,
you're going to lay in your bed to brace
your head for CTE and you're going to
bone smash.
>> Just to clarify, you take a blunt
instrument to your face and repeatedly
hit it.
>> I'll typically use my fist. Braden
didn't wake up one day and just decide
to hit himself in the face with a
hammer. It was that checklist, that
to-do list that got him there one tick
at a [music] time. And here's the thing.
All that cosmetic work that he's done
hasn't fixed the core problem. Now, I
don't mean this to pick on him, but
notice how off he is in this interview.
He looks very uncomfortable. He's unable
to make eye contact, and he's blinking
very quickly. The presence, the
charisma, that feeling good that looks
Maxing promised [music] isn't there.
Now, see how Kevin reacts in a similar
situation.
>> Everybody tell me what y'all saying
about me.
>> What are these for?
>> Oh, that's a sit on.
>> I hate that. just dressed like a paw
bear.
[laughter]
>> Notice what Kevin actually does when
they make fun of his height. He doesn't
deflect. He doesn't shut it down. He
sits in the joke completely and then
turns it around. That's what integrated
confidence looks like at least some of
the time. He sees this as a game and
he's happy to play it cuz he knows his
self-worth isn't on the line. And
because he's playing from that place, he
absolutely crushes the social
interaction. Notice he's being playful,
not shamefilled here. Now, here's
Clavicular's version of a similar thing.
Isabella, I'm going to give her a around
a 4.75 out of 10.
>> What Clvicular is doing to other people
is the thing that was done to him. He
was taught early on that he was a
number. So, he learned to see himself as
a number and therefore other people as
numbers, too. It appears as if this
shame got systematized into his
worldview. Kevin's height was never what
held him back. What held him back was
believing that it was something that he
needed to feel ashamed of. The moment
that he stopped believing that,
everything in his life changed. Because
confidence isn't just the absence of
insecurity or the absence of flaws. It's
being okay with people seeing your
apparent flaws. So, here's what I found
helps. You identify one insecurity that
you have been quietly managing. And you
know that cuz you spend a lot of time
trying to hide it from other people. And
then instead of managing it right now,
just say it out loud. Then, if you feel
comfortable, share it with one person
you're close to. Now, I'll go first. and
you guys aren't necessarily the person
I'm closest to, but I've worked on this
in the past. One thing that has been
beautifully challenging about being
Charlie from Charisma on Command is that
people will come up to me in public and
just expect me to like perform charisma.
I actually remember one time being out
at a bar and feeling like I had to go
talk to strangers just to prove to the
people that had surrounded me that I
could do it, right? It was to reinforce
the person that I was online. Now, the
truth is much more nuanced than that
because sometimes I do love being
extroverted. I do all of the things that
I talk about on the channel and [music]
that can be genuinely great. But other
times I don't feel like performing. I
just want to be the introverted kid that
actually started this channel. So, one
thing that I want to do a better job of,
especially having sat with this video,
is to bring more of my whole self to the
internet so I'm not living as much
behind this persona. Now, I started a
Dungeons and Dragons YouTube channel a
few years back, and I'm going to start a
Charlie Hooper channel to talk about the
things that matter to me, but maybe
aren't on brand for Charisma on Command.
And the point is not to ask you to
subscribe to these. It's just that I
stop hiding the parts of myself that
I've been managing thinking about what
other people will feel about them.
You'll probably find that the same
feeling is true for whatever you've been
quietly hiding. And more importantly,
you'll stop spending so much time
judging yourself. And by the way, if you
do start to share more of your authentic
self with more people, it doesn't mean
that you totally drop any concern for
performance or how you're coming across.
Everything that I have learned as I
became Charlie from Charisma on Command
is still extremely valuable to me. So if
you are interested in those skills about
how to feel more confident in groups,
how to be more charismatic when
communicating, how to give a speech that
people respond to, you might be
interested in checking out Charisma
University. It's had tens of thousands
of students go through it. 30 days long,
fully guaranteed. And here's what one
student had to say about the course.
Charisma University helped me to turn on
my charismatic side like a button. I
started to talk with this girl that is
today my girlfriend. Another member
wrote, "I was always a party killer.
After completing the course, I'm already
called the life of the party, and old
school mates tell me I'm a completely
different person. I received a job
offer, and when I asked why they wanted
me," this was their answer. "Your
charisma and your ability to connect
with everyone are rare and are of great
value to the company." Because we offer
a full 60-day money back guarantee, you
can try the course completely riskfree.
So, I hope you're interested. Either
way, I hope you get something from this
video, and I look forward to seeing you
in the next one.